1 buitengewoon unieke stap van Geert wilders is
er was veel weerstand tegen zijn mogelijke premierschap
ook bij mogelijke coalitiepartners
maar het feit dat hij nu heeft gezegd
nadat hij ook allerlei inhoudelijke punten
van zijn partij
vooral op islamvlak
bereid is opzij te zetten
hij ook die andere hoofdprijs
van plan is opzij te zetten
namelijk de bewoner van het torentje in Nederland
ja dat is toch eigenlijk 1 stap
die zijn weerga niet Kent
wilders heeft er dus buitengewoon
veel voor over om zijn partij
de PVV het kabinet in te krijgen
er is echt 1 akkoord gesloten tussen die 4 partijen
waarin zij Allen hebben gezegd
wij stappen het kabinet niet in
we blijven in de kamer
dat geldt dus ook voor je zult dus
en je hoort ook uit de VVD
dat ze niet van plan is 1 truc uit te halen
er komt niet ineens 1 andere partijleider
waardoor ze door kan schrijven
zij zal in de kamer blijven zitten
en zal dus op zoek moeten naar ministers
voor 1 kabinet
dat is toch echt wel de bedoeling
dat het 1 soort extra parlementair karakter
zal krijgen dat zie je al aan de premier
dat wordt waarschijnlijk iemand van buiten
er zullen
meer ministers worden gezocht van buiten de politiek
om om met hun kennis vooral
de dossiers verder te krijgen in Nederland
maar er zullen ook wel ministers
worden gezocht in politiek Den Haag zelf
want ja de partijleiders blijven in de kamer
maar er mag best wel in de fracties van de partijen
worden gezocht naar mogelijke ministerskandidaten
het wordt 1 mixje
en in die zin wordt het echt met 1 premier van buiten
iets wat we nog niet gezien hadden